yorkshire in northern england
four hours by car from london
here guests at the rudding park hotel
can make the most of the bucolic
surroundings
whether playing a round of golf
or sampling some of yorkshire's finest
cuisine
people come from far near to enjoy the
traditional english sunday roast
today one of the hotel's 20 chefs
matthew wilkinson is going to let us in
on the secret of the region's most
famous dish yorkshire pudding
not to be confused uh with with it with
a pudding or dessert it's basically a
batter which says eggs flour and milk
mixed together cooked in a very hot oven
and traditionally served with um
roast beef
rutting park even has a resident expert
stephanie moon gives the chefs tips on
recipes and ingredients
first of all she recommends regional
products
today she's buying yorkshire pudding
ingredients at the local farm shop
the last five ten years have seen such a
revival of farm shops because people are
wanting to buy local produce they want
to buy freshly made bread they want to
buy free-range eggs from down the road
food miles is very important and
something that you know we're all
starting to take more and more notice of
she even buys the meat for the roast
here
back in the hotel kitchen matthew
wilkinson has the oven ready and waiting
at 210 degrees celsius
whisk flour eggs and milk together in a
large bowl to form a smooth batter
pour through a sieve to get rid of every
last lamp grease a muffin tin with oil
and heat it for five minutes in the oven
if you want to do that then you just end
up with a really small
yoshi pudding and also when it rises you
get a nice hole in the middle
which is where you put the gravy at the
end
quickly pour the batter into the
sizzling hot oil
then return the tin to the oven and cook
for half an hour until your perfect pud
is formed hollow puffed up and golden
brown
it's nice and hollow inside and that's
where we're going to pour the gravy it's
gonna soak up into the extra pudding
it's gonna nicely use out when you cut
into it
for the roast beef season the meat
generously with salt pepper and sprigs
of thyme
roast at 220 degrees celsius in a
preheated oven for around 45 minutes to
an hour depending on its weight
dinner is served
perfectly cooked roast beef and
yorkshire pudding with roast potatoes
and gravy
and now it's time for the taste test
yorkshire cuisine expert stephanie moon
and journalist elaine lam are ready and
waiting
lem has written a book about the humble
roots of yorkshire pudding
back then only the rich ate the meat
but the poorer people got to eat the
batter pudding from underneath which is
what became a yorkshire pudding it was
full of the flavor of the meat the
drippings from the meat and it's kind of
stuck with it the two have gone together
for centuries
these days yorkshire pudding can be
enjoyed by all
in fact the roast beef's tasty
accompaniment often steals the show
yorkshire pudding a british culinary
classic and not too tricky to try at
home